اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في اولي عمليه من نوعها
في القدس منذ سته سنوات تفجيران بمحطتين
للحافلات يؤديان الى مقتل اسرائيلي وجرح
وسلطات الاحتلال تغلق مداخل المدينه وترفع
درجات التاهب الامني ودعوات يمنيه متطرفه
لاجتياح
مواقع عسكريه في ريفي حلب والقامشلي تتعرض
لقصف تركي بحسب ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه واردوغان يقولون الاحدث اظهرت
ان القوه التي اعطى الضمانات بعدم استهداف
تركيا من مناطق سيطرتها لم تفي بوعدها
ويؤكد ان العمليه البريه ستبدا في الوقت
المناسب
مساعي من مجموعه السبع لوضع السقف لاسعار
النفط الروسي بين خمسه 65 دولارا
و70$
الى البلدان التي ستضع سقفا لسعر نفطها
والبرلمان الاوروبيه يتبنى قرارا يصنف
روسيا دوله نراعيه للارهاب
في ظهوره الاول في كاس العالم في قطر 2022
منتخب المغرب يكتفي بالتعادل السلبي امام
كرواتيا وصيف العالم اسود الاطلس انتزعوا
نقطه ثمينه في مشوارهم نحو المنافسه على
بلوغ الدور الثاني في البطوله الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]